leute was geht und herzlich willkommen
zum heutigen video ihr seht schon hinter
mir
wie gestern versprochen die
schlechtesten youtube-videos
beziehungsweise schlechte youtube-videos
aufgehängt und ich will jetzt zusammen
mit sky seine fußball change aufnehmen
wie wir zusammen auf diese dinge hier
schießen auf diesem feld gibt es immer
punkte zum beispiel 50 in diesem fall
die schwer zu treffen sind kriegen in
der regel ein bisschen mehr punkte und
wer mehr punkte hat gewinnt und es gibt
auch eine es gibt auch eine strafe für
den verlierer also wenn ihr wissen wollt
was es ist bleibt dran und ich würd
sagen wir legen los jetzt 53 21 knapp
knapp leute 3 2 1 gerade in lampen
schießen video gemacht weil bewachten
fahrzeug an
es ist so gestört dieser typ trifft
einfach immer die latte
er mag ja beschließen beide fünfmal
übrigens beide bisher ein schuss kein
treffer die latte getroffen hatte
wirst du lustig dass wir beide genau
hintereinander die larven treten wo wir
gerade abschließen video gemacht
ich will mich ausdenken statt zu
schiessen der richtigen cool dabei aber
auch zu wissen glaube auch doppelte
punktzahl volley oder direktabnahme
erst am 5
er schadet vielleicht probiere wir
gleich noch mal los geht wirklich
probiert noch 20 punkte für die
eigentlich real als ob du drei abgeräumt
hat ja was jetzt 650 für stehen also
eigentlich gerne
eigentlich schon aber dann hat sich das
erledigt wir sind es 350 350 150 punkte
okay wir wollen hier mal nicht von 18 1
mal mister mit leading katja glaser
witze und wo ist mein liebling nie el
mabhuh alle drei abgeräumt was machen
wir jetzt
ich habe 115 20 das ein bisschen
authentisch machen vielleicht
wissenschaften
also leute war ich habe vier farmer
abgeschossen eigentlich verboten
deshalb gewinnt sie passten ja spaß
leute als spaß weiß 150 jetzt kann ich
es schaffen kann es noch schaffen das
schaffen
hey ich hätte nicht gedacht dass das
alles acht fällen aber eigentlich schon
sind das im selben kilo wand ich habe
ihn sogar getroffen und mit ankündigung
im profifußball vielleicht ja wobei ich
kann ich noch schaffen theoretisch eine
fachgerechte seite aber du musst dir
überlegen sind als ultra schwierig zu
treffen ja wie gut diese strafe hat
dieser youtube bekommen hatte youtube
eine strafe die so krass ist erwartet an
diesem tag diesem universum alter auch
mein erster flugversuch mal getroffen
vielleicht auf der seite
schade schade aber leute ich würde sagen
wir verdoppeln die wiederum fliegen oder
weil die echt schwer zu treffen sind
solche verdoppeln mit ich sagen hier
agitato guten fußball alltag junger
wieder versucht ich fast vom glauben ab
max ist normalerweise immer unter uns
gemacht der größte handball fußball und
heute trifft er einfach mit einem
faktenblatt bonner das winkel kratzte es
ist nicht immer leicht
wie soll ich jetzt sagen und auch ganz
okay aber es sind immer leicht den
verband nummer beste fußballspieler auf
diesem dreck planeten zu sein ja aber
ich komme also laufenberg da leute
wirklich mal ist es so krass ist die
ganze treppe ich kann überhaupt kein
fußball spielt eigentlich schon was ist
eigentlich sonst ein ziemlicher körper
klaus aber heute trifft er so ultras
nicht zu das ist mein letzter schluss
eigentlich ist man erkennt auch an
meinem outfit
ich spiele regelmäßig fußball
fußballschuhe fußball zu sebastian krieg
eine sporthose und schäbig die 69
die zeit weil ich ja schon wieder die
latte getroffen leute wieder deutlich
erhöhen die latte getroffen für dinger
einfach was macht er
hallo ich glaube ich hatte heute echt
ein bisschen glück aber das ist noch
nicht vorbei wir fahren jetzt nach hause
und dann kriegt sie was schon seine
bestraft auf jeden fall gespannt was es
sein wird wir fahren jetzt nach hause
und dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder was
nur was zu sagen vor dem strafen
bekommst okay leute ist jetzt ein
bisschen später und wir sind bei
sebastians bestrafungen angekommen und
zwar wird sie was jetzt von mir
geschwind man am rand die lippen also wo
man gleich überall den lippenstift
auftragen wird
da sind die lippen dann nimmt man den
lippenstift bisschen schön deckendes rot
setzt man hier an meint dass alles aus
schön kreis füllen
das ist schon relativ weiter auf den
lippen
nur stilvoll lippenstift des tages ich
würde mal die nasa nicht okay so dort
ist sie schon mal ganz schön aus
für die lashes macht mir noch ist das
jemals wieder runter ich weiß nicht wer
es nicht eigentlich nur nicht was in die
augen
da müssen wir die bisschen hoch pinseln
okay da ist noch ein grashalm auf der
anderen seite drastischen relativ gut
aus wir gehen ein bisschen auf den auf
den bad boy look und machen das hier so
anderer seite können so ja ok folglich
muss ich das noch machen das war's leute
das war's der ferry ah okay leute also
das passiert im fußball gegen nicht
verliert ich hoffe mal das video
durchgefallen falls ja dass sein
da schaut auf sebastians lange schießt
change an die es unter der beschreibung
verlinkt und ich glaube er macht jetzt
irgend etwas unüberlegtes so was kann
ich gerecht sein
ja ich würde gerne ganz gerne boden
versinken ehrlich gesagt